[Music]
hello I get to be inexplicable yellow
now to such as life on the road where
apparently the first thing that happens
is you lose your camcorder I don't even
know where I left mine no idea I had it
then I didn't have it anymore and yes
this is the last video of Brotherhood
2.1 good Bob Brotherhood 2.1 I won't be
too sad to see you go I liked it better
when we were doing one or two a week
that was pretty freakin sweet I know
none of you are gonna like it's gonna be
a lot easier for Gemini especially since
now we're on the road all the time
though Jon never managed to edit and
record an entire video for me like I did
for him while on the road maybe he will
do that for me next week I have another
song for you today even though it's not
Wednesday it's Thursday it's been part
of the gatherings part of the Tour de
nerdfighting
John I have done this at some of the
gatherings it's a nerdfighter chant I
kind of want everybody to know it so
that we can all do it together that goes
like this yes we are nerdfighters in the
world is and luck because we increase
the awesome and we decrease the suck so
if you want to just listen to that a
couple of times
learn the words and we can sing it
together at the nerdfighter events that
would be fun so on the way home from the
Knoxville Tennessee nerdfighter
gathering John said to me Hank you don't
have to worry about making your video
it's really late yeah but all the
nerdfighters really want to hear from
you is you making funny noises
why don't you what for me funny noises
cuz I can do that you buddy good batik
of people who printed my album misread
so jokes as fifty jokes which makes
sense if you're not a nerdfighter so
jokes doesn't make any sense at all but
fifty jokes does and this doesn't have
any impact on the actual album they just
did it on the order form and they kept
talking to me about my album fifty jokes
and I kept saying whatever I don't care
what you call it that gave me an idea
for a video I kinda want to do a video
with fifty jokes if you would like to
put some jokes in the comments then I
can choose my favorite jokes and I can
put together my video with fifty of ever
jokes I mean I got a lot of favorite
jokes already some of them are not so
appropriate throwing you some of my
jokes and some of your jokes maybe the
next nerdfighter gathering we can talk
about jokes the gatherings have
continued to go pretty awesomely I'm
very glad to say that I have stopped
messing up quite so often during my
songs though still haven't gotten
through one without messing up that's
just part of life I guess
messing up tomorrow we will be in
Gadsden Alabama and it will be awesome
and then we're taking a day off and then
we're mood on John I'll see you in the
morning when we get into the minivan and
we resumed touring the dirt fighting and
art fighters I will see you guys soon
especially if you're not Obama